[Music]
it didn't seem too long ago but we're
actually in the last few weeks of 2020
already
time's flown by largely in part to the
situation of the world at large
nevertheless the recovery of the anime
industry is a tale for the ages and i
still find myself
amazed at japanese resiliency that
managed to still bring us these shows
that we love
so for today i'll be going through 10 of
the best anime fights in 2020
because let's be honest half of the guys
who like shonen series
like anime for the fantasy and the
fights and we'll be taking a look at the
best of the both of them today
as a precaution there will be spoilers
on this list but i'll try to keep them
to a minimum
also i won't be including stuff from
fall 2020 even though i've already had
some candidates in mind i'll be saving
that for the full
fight video or maybe a volume 2 of this
video now before anything i'd like you
to subscribe and help this channel reach
its next milestone your contribution
would be much appreciated
we start the list with the fight where
everyone teams up against demon in
black clover
[Music]
it's been a while but i legitimately
think the black clovers become an
underrated show
it may be because of the bad publicity
it had when it first aired but it has
become a really enjoyable show now but
not a lot of people still seem to be
watching it a battle shonen is nothing
without good fights
but we see a prime example of what black
clover brings to the table with this
fight
this fight pretty much encapsulates what
a shonen fight is
tense circumstances a seemingly
unbeatable foe
old reliable allies pitching in and
joining the fight with their own awesome
stunts
seeing arsenal surpass his limits whilst
the opening music players in the
background sent chills down my spine
really the finishing move is probably
one of my favorite black clover moments
this year
period it's too bad that many people
sleep on black clover but i think it's
done pretty well for itself given the
circumstances
[Music]
coming up next is a fight from gleipner
shuichi and claire versus hikarva
ikuba
the dynamic duo of shuichi and claire
had a tough customer as their first
challenge while getting used to their
powers they'd barely gotten an idea of
the whole coin collecting business and
their powers before they get shoved into
the battle royale by hikava and her
powerful limbs the fight itself is not
that swingy as when shuichi and claire
got a hang of things they dispatched
their first opponent without too much
effort the thing ends up with us getting
a glimpse of claire's ruthless side but
not before we get to see some great
animation
courtesy of pine jam i think that the
fight belongs here because it's one of
the things that put glyph near on the
map
thanks to how the fight was done in a
way that out does its manga counterpart
the encounter helped glipe near break
through and become one of the more
popular shows in the admittedly dry
spring season it then led the way to
more amazing fights that we'll see down
the line but in terms of actual visuals
none of them come close to this one we
continue with something big
misaka versus doppelganger in the finale
of
railgun tea
now i know that this isn't the fight
that i talked about the last time i
featured railgun t but while that battle
between side characters has all the
makings of a grand fight
i think it just lacked a bit of umph in
terms of spectacle and scale compared to
what we have as an ending to railgun tea
where else could you see a giant
godzilla in anime and a showcase of how
badass misaka really is i mean before
this you'd probably think how she's one
of the weaker level fives thanks to how
normal she seemed amongst the gallery of
sociopaths or downright insane people
it makes you forget that misaka is
actually the third ranked among them
well look no further than this fight
that caps off railgun t's storied run
which sees her face off against a
seemingly unbeatable foe with
near-perfect adaptability the run in by
the rest of scavenger as uneasy allies
also brought me joy when i first watched
this finale now i hope that this
convinced you to give rail gunty a shot
especially if you enjoyed the previous
seasons for an anime on its third season
it hasn't lost its edge ever since the
series started a decade ago well here's
a battle featuring a side character now
as we move on to berkoli versus vector
[Music]
the last core of sword art online's war
of underworld went off to a fast start
after the controversial start to the
season i can see that a lot of people
were brought back by the amazing fight
that followed an episode after and it
wasn't kirito's return that got people
most excited that would have to wait
until around
five to six more episodes it was
berkoli's battle against
dark lord vector prior to this fight we
barely saw much of what berkoli could
really do but this should prove that he
more than deserves his moniker of being
the legendary hero and the strongest
integrity knight
going toe to toe with the lord of
darkness is next to impossible but the
leader of the integrity knights did it
as a novel reader i can say that some
details were omitted which should have
made the fight even more amazing but i'm
generally satisfied with what a1 gave us
this fight might not have been the most
important one or the best adapted in
this core but in terms of visuals and
presentation this fight completely blows
everything else out of the water
a1 really bringing their a game to their
cash cow franchise
we continue the battles against
impossible obstacles with the entire
sequence
versus tiamat in the last part of fate
grand order babylonia
now i think i've cheated with this one a
little bit why well
i won't be talking about a single fight
but i'll be compiling
everything into a sequence the whole
sequence against diamond as she marches
towards uruk is nothing
short of awesome noble phantasms being
thrown
everywhere so many character arcs
finding their calls some
really amazing scenes like
quetzalcoatl's double noble phantasm and
the mash and merlin combo for me it's
this series of episodes that make
babylonia the most fun i've had
in a fate anime in a while it helps that
the music choice for these scenes are my
jam
and along with the voice acting it
really enhanced these moments
if you're looking for a fate animator
watch make sure you give this one a
whirl don't be intimidated with how it's
supposed to be towards the end of the
grand order storyline you can completely
watch babylonia as a standalone without
prior knowledge of fate
we move on to a non-japanese anime on
the list like this one from white cat
legend
[Music]
if you've been following i've recently
featured this fight a few lists back and
looking at the stuff that i've watched
this year i can proudly say that i made
the right call looking at the year as a
whole
this final fight still holds up really
well but you could watch it without
context and still be entertained that's
not to say that the fight has no
emotional weight behind it though but
this one i'm pretty sure most people
like for its choreography
and just how complicated each sequence
is it's a complete chore to animate yes
but thanks to the amazing team who
bought us this series we've got
something so aesthetically pleasing we
don't have grand attacks like noble
phantasms that take up 80
of the screen in explosions but as some
say less is more
and simple is better
[Applause]
if you've been paying attention to my
videos lately you won't be surprised
to see this on the list
four killer five elements may be short
but it brings with it a kind of
animation
excellence that's been sorely lacking in
a number of its contemporaries maybe
it's due to being less mainstream and
thus being under the radar that way the
team have less pressure and probably
deal with less deadlines whatever the
reason may be
two thumbs up for the work they did in
this sequence in fact if you were to
tell me which fog he'll fight i have to
feature i'd consider this
interchangeable with the bridge scene
that i featured on another list
make sure to check that video out too if
you've got the time back to this topic
though
this thing is insane come on try playing
the video in slow motion and you can see
how much work got put into the sequence
in order to give us this experience i
had a hard time following the action at
times and that's not a negative thing
not in this context it instead adds to
the experience of the scene and it's an
experience
that you rarely get these days you knew
and my hero fight is coming sooner down
the line didn't you wait no more now
because our next entry
is endeavour versus hood
[Music]
the latest season of my hero academia
really gave us one spectacular send-off
it shows off some lit visuals as well as
a big redemption for everyone's favorite
bad dad
it's a fight filled with high stakes
because quite honestly i think that the
whole of japan is screwed if endeavour
and horse can't take down the high end
no move when hood began seeking out
strong opponents
he got what he wanted and it was a
spectacle that we all got the fight's
not a stomp and is a very intense back
and forth exchange
with a lot of fake finishes a lot of
times you think that the fight's over
but the combatants just keep coming back
plus we get to see a plethora of
endeavors moves that couldn't have been
animated
any better it's just simply beautiful i
personally still put united states of
smash as my favorite fight but this
one's right up there too
in terms of how impactful it was
second place on this list is jin vs devi
from god of high school
god of high school entered with a bang
but unfortunately it can't carry that
momentum to the end when critics called
god of high school and anime that's just
for the fight
it makes you think that the fight should
at least live up to the hype now for the
most part i think the fights more than
pull their weight and still make god of
high school an exciting watch at the
forefront of many fights is jin vs devi
it's a tough decision for me but i give
this fight the nod because of the sheer
hype and stakes it has going for it we
just saw david demolish his previous
opponent
and we finally learned why he seemed so
hell-bent on winning in the hopes of
saving his friend davie had taken on a
much more sadistic turn at fighting and
this new fighting style
surely gave jin a run for his money the
actual fight has to be seen to be
believed as we've got a brilliant
barrage of attacks that showcase both
fighters intensities and will to win
the best part about it is that it ends
with the classic happy ending for
everyone with bonds forged through fire
and a renewed will to face tomorrow
you can find gems in the most unlikely
of places
and that saying couldn't be any more
true with the number one entry for
today's list
that one fight from hitori noshita
if any of you expected to get a fight
this good from a chinese anime
raise your hand if you expected it to
come from the third season of hitori
noshita
keep your hands raised okay now if you
kept your hand raised you know you're
lying okay the series as a whole isn't
too popular and who would have expected
this gem of a fight to be hidden in its
third season of all places heck i won't
even consider it much of a third season
but more of a transition to a possible
fourth season
yet in this unassuming transition season
of a niche show
we have some of the sleekest and
smoothest animation for a fight scene in
as far back as i can remember
for how much is going on and how fast
things are moving it amazes me how the
animators just knocked it out the park
with this one
in terms of dramatic stakes the fight
might be nowhere near the top but in
terms of animation and fight
choreography
it certainly takes the cake for the best
fights in 2020
so how did you find this list do you
think that 2020 has been a good year in
terms of anime fights are there other
anime fights this year that i've missed
out on there's so much more that i'd
love to hear from you on so make sure to
chime in and give me your thoughts
through the comments section down below
as usual if you enjoyed the list and
want more hit that like button
subscribe and ring the bell so that you
can be the first in line next time i'll
see you next time
on vini tube
[Music]
you